the number one quality of a successful
entrepreneur is this
I still get like comments YouTube in
like basis right
I look like sign I look like you Joe
things are fine you know I don't I don't
need to be their ambitious but that's
the problem your income zone is your
comfort zone need motivation watch a top
10 with belief nation
he's deadlock and here's my take on his
top ten rules a success vol 11 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one injure pain many years ago I had
this conversation with my mentor and he
asked me the question Dan what do you
think is the number one quality of an
entrepreneur and I said many many things
I said talents and I said team and I
said a good idea I said many many many
things and no he said the number one
quality of a successful entrepreneur is
this and that is the ability to endure
pain for a long period of time didn't
talk about the Ferrari didn't talk about
the big house paying for a long period
of time is that you what are you willing
to give up what price are you willing to
pay to accomplish success to build your
business I could tell you any successful
entrepreneurs that I know almost all of
them experienced pain for a long period
of time before they accomplished even
just a little bit of success rule number
two ignored the haters I still get like
comments YouTube like basis right I look
like psy I look like Yuto every day I
get that that's okay that's okay they're
not who I want to impact right I say
remember if you have a million people
watching you on your content 10% don't
like you 100,000 people going out ten
million people watching my content
that's a million people not liking
million people like and because he was
so the rock and blunt and provocative
right like it's right so people hate me
really hate me but it's not like oh I
can't don't like this either
hey yo God like that you die like it's
like very like direct stuff right
because it's too
it irks them right yeah by the same time
keep watching my stuff up it's hilarious
outward I think like our haters
everything the same hey common you suck
watch all my video you can see like
negative comment right there same dude
immediately my stuff buddy keep watching
my stuff rule number three overcome
fears you see what holds a lot of people
back is fear fear of success fear of
failure fear of making a mistake think
about it before you do something you're
saying to yourself well what if it
doesn't work or what if or if I lose
money and what if what if I make a
mistake then what happens what if I
don't know what to do what if I can't
figure this out there what if what if
what if what if what if it does work you
see always remember fear is an acronym
it stands for false evidence appearing
real
it's nothing more than a made-up story
in your own mind so do you have your
fearful ego
holding you back rule number four start
with gratitude I thought that happiness
is a destination if I I get to some
place I make certain amount of money if
I owned a certain amount of things then
I would be happy
then I will lies as I am now older and a
little bit more mature and a little bit
wiser that is not happiness it's not
something that you seek is something
that's already within you but a lot of
times we are blocking it so you think
about why people are depressed why feel
unhappy usually it's because when their
expectation because you know it's our
expectation of how your life should look
like where you should be at this by this
point and your reality when your
expectation and your reality when they
don't match up you get depressed you
feel very very unhappy because this is
where you are this is where you think
you should be and the bigger this gap
the more unhappy you are so to be
happier you can do two things you can
either lower your expectation so that
your gap is not as large example you
want to make a billion dollars and
you're making now a thousand dollars a
month well you will feel very unhappy
they are very much unhappy because this
is where I should be
it is why man well if you lo a spectator
ah he's in the 100 bucks you low
expectation I'm gonna make a a hundred
and two dollars right now you're making
a hundred ok now you're not so bad I'm
gonna show two dollars right that's okay
so you can lower expectation
which is what you can do or you can now
change the reality how you can shorten
the gap right that's what I achieve at
us how do you match how could you push
and challenge your reality to match to
expectation you could do that or the
other way down look at it is this when I
start the day with attitude of gratitude
coming from a place of giving coming
from a place of love coming from a place
of I have enough right I have enough
because whatever your goal is you're
getting the same thing but just more
right you have one car you want two cars
you want three cars but it's the same
thing if you're not grateful you have
appreciate what you have now you're not
gonna appreciate what you get then so I
am grateful with what I have I start
with that while achieving what I want
right I'm grateful with what I have Wow
achieving what I won NYX when I start
from this place I just find that I'm
much happier I like today I'm a happy
guy believe me also if you want to learn
how to have more confidence check about
250 for confidence series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
after you practice Marshall you develop
this natural self confidence not
cockiness when you develop this natural
self confidence rule number five have a
big vision to be a great leader to
inspire other people here's what I
believe in that you must have something
that it's bigger than yourself in order
to inspire people in order to enroll
people into your vision example if you
talk to your employee talk to your team
member and you say hey you know what
this is why we're doing this so that I
could make enough money so that I could
retire or so that I could build this
business so that I could be living the
the 10 hour week or twelve hour work
week to be a lifestyle entrepreneur see
that doesn't inspire anybody because
it's all about me me me me me so to be a
great leader to inspire other people
you can't even vision that is so big
there's so compelling that other people
want to be part of that
right it's like imagine you are the
captain of this ship and you're saying
hey this is where we're going we're
going to this island and it's going to
be great and we are going to to have all
these great things when we get there and
that's like wow you know people look at
that say yeah I want to be part of that
but I want you I want to join this
journey I want it I want to join
alongside it and be alongside with you
and maybe there's some obstacles there
will always be challenges there will be
waves in the ocean but that's okay I
want to join you and help you to fight
along and be alongside with you going
through this journey so I believe very
much their leader needs to think about
what is your mission rule number six
understand the industry don't start a
business if you don't understand the
industry I always ask this question
before you start any business and that
is and I'm asking you right now why'd
you and why now if your answer is all I
just want to make some money
you're gonna fail why you and why now
what qualifies you to be in this space
right now not what I just saw on
Facebook oh that sounds like a good idea
this person this guy's making so much
money doing this I should jump into that
to know why you and why now in order to
make money in any industry you have to
understand the industry if you don't
know the industry first you have to
learn the industry let's say you want to
go open up a restaurant now I'm not
saying that's a good idea
but let's say you want to open up a
restaurant well isn't a good idea to
just go work at a restaurant see what's
the day-to-day operation like what's it
like to to work in a restaurant
before you open up a restaurant so you
have to know your industry rule number
seven don't be the know-it-all person
see when I was broke I thought I know it
all I don't need to read books I know
what I'm doing I was studying all these
businesses and guess what none of them
worked because I thought I knew what I
was talking about guess what I didn't
know she okay you don't know she
see the know-it-all always thinking they
know everything keep doing the same
thing again and again and expect a
different result that's the very
definition of insanity rule number eight
build work-life integration when you are
an entrepreneur right when you are
running your own company it is not
something that you do is who you are
what is who you are this doesn't turn
off there's no such thing as oh well you
know I don't want to work on weekends I
take the two-week vacation when you're
entrepreneur you're going all the time
because I always say that's why I don't
watch sports I don't need to watch
sports to get some chips zero
entrepreneurship it is the most
competitive sport in the world because
when you watch any sport game guess what
you're playing for 30 minutes 60 minutes
whatever how much amount of time well
with entrepreneur 24/7 someone somewhere
is trying to kick your ass somewhere
someone somewhere they try to steal your
customers they are trying to grab market
share it is 24/7 so we have to be
thinking about how can we be better how
can we serve our customer better how can
we deliver more value this is ongoing
there's no work-life balance or how to
separate the two
I don't meal my life around my business
I built my business around my lifestyle
preference so right now I'm going
somewhere I'm gonna do an interview
I'm filming I'm creating content I'm
connecting with you
that's integration when I'm traveling
I'm traveling for business at the same
time I will be travel for pleasure take
a few days off it's integration versus I
work at work I work at work oh my god
man I can't take this no more I need to
escape from this I need to avoid this I
need to go somewhere and then from there
I need a totally unplugged so don't
bother me for a week
oh man I'll take a vacation I'm Tina
Beach doing nothing and then come back
oh my god man you got a dragging your
feet now I gotta get back to work it
doesn't work that way
so I will find a time in between how do
we charge my battery now in my case I
like movies so I don't need to take you
know two weeks off in order to recharge
what I need maybe Jenny and I we go to
watch movie two hours out with Josh a
good night's sleep
of the charge and back at the game rule
number nine get out of your comfort zone
things are fine you know I don't need to
be there ambitious but that's the
problem your income zone is your comfort
zone your comfort zone is your income
zone when you get complacent when you
get comfortable you are not growing
remember when you're not growing you are
dying so do you have this Eagle that is
holding you back right now and what are
you gonna do about it
and rule number ten the last one for a
very special bonus clip is create your
legacy only do you realize during your
platform of closing career your speaking
career like that's all I'm gonna focus
on impact and with serving
while their two incidents that happen so
first is when I hit 30 years old there
one day I got in the morning of tears
coming down much yeah I know it's crying
a little while I was crying I would just
have this depression coming over me
which I'm then I don't get depressed
right it doesn't happen to and I realize
I've opted at that point the way I lived
my life that I've grown a company I made
a lot of money but I wasn't being who I
wanted to be right because I was 20 to
30 years old like the seafood that you
see today more and more pearl but you
can see from time to time I have that
yeah right but I was all that before
yeah I was all that like that right oh
is that anymore okay wasn't shooting
very very feel very nice okay wasn't
just arrogant because I felt I'm so
smart and I'm smart but I it's a wrong
attitude right so when I hit 30 years
old when that happens depression and
that's when I realize okay I need to
look for something else
so remember like my both mom and dad
their pearls right and my pick-ten my
mentors like extreme Ruby yeah so right
the first so I thought that was the way
you have to be to be successful I didn't
have any other role models I have five
father figure
so from there I tried to be big then
okay like do what he does as an author
and it wasn't and I I got to a certain
point but I wasn't happy so that was
first turning point right okay I said I
realized I went to deep dive in terms of
spiritual work in terms of even well
it's just work
I did a lot of studying and I found mine
kind of new path right so that's number
one second is my father passed away when
I chasing a deal that was just chasing
the next success and I thought that will
make him proud well in fact he passed
away
I can like that a mess mr. chance that's
one I realize that's not what life is
about because when my father passed away
I'm like okay it's it's real like the
people closest to you they could take a
leave and then now I started asking
what's my legacy right what what I want
to be right do I do I want to keep going
I can be a lot of money which I'm very
good at making money no problem mm-hmm
right but then I would think about one
thing they also when I went to the Bruce
Lee grave in Seattle right
you know I was there every five minute
there's someone going there hmm every
five minutes after all these years every
five minutes from all kinds of
backgrounds all kinds of crunchy
countries people bring flowers and all
that I'm like that's a legacy right
that's a legacy he's an iconic Marsha
Waters actor that lives through all this
age right and I'm like I'm not saying
like I'm boosting it I'm just saying
that Wow
right so then inspires me that's when I
shift my focus into now I've got to
start a bonus skip from Danny on how to
follow your path that I think is gonna
be really helpful for you but before
that it's time for the three point
landing question let's go from just
watching a video to take an action here
we go question number one what's the
legacy that you want to create number
two what's the fear you need to overcome
and number three how are you gonna
ignore the haters along the way you
think about college first of all just
because you go to college it doesn't
guarantee you success in life and I'm
not saying go to college you don't go to
college it depends on what is that you
want to do if you want to be a lawyer
doctor engineer accountant yes you need
to go to college because you need that
piece of paper even to to get a job in
order to even enter that profession
right but if you want to do other things
in 1983 there was a psychologist called
Howard Gardner's and he talks about that
human beings we actually have nine
different types of intelligence nine
different types intelligence so
basically we have musical kinesthetics
a linguistic a mathematical so you have
like many many different types of
intelligence so what happens is the
biggest problem with college is the only
focus on one or two types of
intelligence so maybe you are not
book-smart corn corn right that you are
not very good at memorizing things
because how do you pass exams how do you
get good grades in school what do you
have to do you have to be very good at
memorizing stuff just a few days people
would exam where you'd lock yourself in
a room and I memorize all the answer all
the answers to multiple-choice and then
you take the exam you do okay and then
two days later you completely you just
you forgot everything that you've
learned you're not actually learning
you're just trying to try to memorize
those answers that makes you get good
grades you're not you're not
internalizing everything that you learn
you have you done this before I know you
have I know I have right so that's one
type of intelligence but there's some
people they're just not very good at
that but they're very good with music
right I am horrible with music like my
musical intelligence is like minus ten
when I was a young kid young kid I had a
piano the piano at my at my home in Hong
Kong right and my dad could play a
little bit of piano so my dad thought
maybe you know maybe maybe me I could
also learn to play the piano kind of you
know develop their artistic Musical and
also in Asian culture a little more
sophisticated and go play a piano you
know what let's send let's send and send
my son to let's send Dan to learn piano
always what happens okay I we we we sign
up a class it was just about five ten
minutes away from my home and I would
join the lesson and the music teacher
was teaching me how to play the piano
you ever played keyboards any techno
okay I was so bad the music teacher was
so pissed after about a few lessons he
was so pissed he was using a ruler right
at a time honk all tickets to hit the
hit the kids so they do that so I would
play it would play so back he would like
hit hit my hit my hands at oh no that's
not how you do it and he would hit the
head is it don't that's how he got it
all wrong right and I was playing a
piano that was playing and and it was so
bad I was I would like those I would be
playing imagine the teacher right next
to me I'm playing and I'll be like this
anyway hit hit my hands like stop
potential okay right I got fire from
this school
they have never fired anybody we were
painting it talked to my mom
know your son he will never be able to
play the piano we cannot have a student
like this it is a waste of time but
school they try to put you in this box
yet did you have to behave a certain way
to be successful instead of thinking hey
you know what what are you good at what
are you what are you naturally good at
what are your strengths but school
doesn't custom tailor their curriculum
and teaching based on your strengths
your personality your passion and your
interest that's the biggest problem so
that's why school is designed to create
employees is designed to be almost like
a assembly line right it's not designed
for you to to flourish to to exercise
full exercise of talents or your
creativity all right this is Dan Locke
if you're a fan of Evans work if you
want to know exactly how the model my
success I want to invite you to join me
for a special online training all you
have to do is click on a link below you
can join me for absolutely no charge so
click on link below and I will see you
in class
if you want more dan lock check at the
top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
if your life stinks is your fault we
take responsibility for all action how
money is not the important money doesn't
buy happiness oh my goodness